how do we find the product of two
matrices before we find out how two
matrices are multiplied we need to check
for their compatibility only if they are
compatible can they be multiplied but
wait how do we check for compatibility
how do we know if two matrices can be
multiplied we will come to this don't
worry but before that let me ask you an
easy question let's say we multiply two
numbers 2 & 3 we know that this also
equals 3 times 2 2 times 3 is equal to 3
times 2 this is the commutative property
of multiplication X multiplied by Y will
always be equal to Y multiplied by X if
x and y are numbers but let's say there
are two matrices a and B will a times B
be always equal to B times a the answer
is not always the order in which
matrices are multiplied matters so if we
find out that a times B is compatible it
does not imply that B times a is
compatible we need to check for
compatibility of each of the products
now let's move on to how we can check
for compatibility okay here's the rule
the product a B is compatible if note
that we are talking about a times B here
and not B times a a is the first matrix
and B is the second so the product a B
is compatible if the number of columns
in matrix a is equal to the number of
rows in matrix B yes a B is compatible
only if the number of columns in a is
equal to the number of rows in B let's
see a couple of examples can this matrix
being multiplied with this one we don't
have to multiply we just need to check
the compatibility look at the rule again
a B is compatible if the number of
columns in a is equal to the number of
rows in B here the first matrix has one
column
and the second matrix has one row the
number of columns in this matrix is
equal to the number of rows in this
matrix and hence this multiplication is
possible here's the second example I
encourage you to pause the video and
check if this multiplication is possible
or not for this to be possible the
number of columns in the first matrix
has to be equal to the number of rows in
the second Matrix the first matrix has
one column and the second Matrix has two
rows as one is not equal to two this
multiplication is not possible remember
the simple rule the number of columns in
the first matrix should be equal to the
number of rows in the second keeping
that in mind I want you to complete the
next sentence
assuming a and B are matrices B a will
be compatible if easy this will be
compatible if the number of columns in B
is equal to the number of rows in a it's
the same rule the number of columns in
the first matrix should be equal to the
number of rows in the second is this
multiplication possible two columns
three rows no it is not possible what
about this one three columns and 3 rows
possible now you note that it's easy to
find out if two matrices are compatible
for multiplication the number of columns
in the first matrix should be equal to
the number of rows in the second only
then will the multiplication be possible
a good way to find out if multiplication
is possible is by writing the order of
the matrices let's see how it helps us
look at the first example the first
matrix has 3 rows and 1 column its order
will be 3 by 1 the order of the second
Matrix will be 1 by 2 we see 4 numbers
here
multiplication is possible only if the
second and the third numbers are equal
one is equal to one multiplication
possible the order of this matrix is 2
by 1 and that of this one is also 2 by 1
here 1 is not equal to 2 multiplication
not possible in the third example 2 is
not equal to 3
hence multiplication not possible and in
the 4th 3 is equal to 3
hence multiplication is possible hold on
some of you might be thinking that
writing the orders is a waste of time
and just finding the number of columns
of the first matrix and rows of the
second is enough but there is a reason
why writing the orders helps us yes a
very important reason which we will
cover in the next session